why would the Florida governor use  taxpayer money to send migrants from  Texas to Massachusetts doesn't make any  sense secondly turns out it might have  been criminal because they were lured  with false promises of jobs and possibly  faster paths to their Asylum claims  being adjudicated those were lies  meaning that they were fraudulently  lured we call that Interstate human  trafficking and now there's a criminal  investigation and then maybe most  importantly all these right-wingers keep  talking about these migrants as illegal  immigrants they're not illegal  immigrants when you come to the Border  and make a claim of Asylum and the claim  is uh established legally  until it's adjudicated you were not an  illegal immigrant you were here legally  awaiting the adjudication of your Asylum  claim so it's very quickly gotten dumber  than I even expected it to get